was Tristan Thompson really spotted
kissing multiple other women everything
we know about the alleged cheating
scandal and how Chloe is dealing another
day
another Kardashian scandal only this one
has me shook for Chloe Chloe is expected
to give birth to her first child with
boyfriend Tristan Thompson any minute
now
but what should be a happy time is now
being overshadowed by reports that
Tristan was spotted kissing multiple
other women it all started when the
Daily Mail obtained one video of what
appeared to be Tristan making out with a
mystery woman in New York City well soon
after multiple reports surface of
Tristan allegedly stepping out on Chloe
with other women and it's Tristan the
alleged trifling ways that our et source
says has left
Chloe completely devastated Tristan is a
man Chloe built a life with and saw as
her forever now this is something Ichi
saw firsthand when we were with Chloe
in January what's the most unexpected
gift in all of this gosh is having a
family yeah I think it's important to
show people you can turn your life
around you can go through hell and high
water but you can still come out and
have a beautiful positive happy life see
and now their future is up in the air
our source says Chloe is still in
Cleveland but does not expect her to
make any decisions immediately quote as
always the baby is the priority
Chloe is focused on having a healthy
delivery now if you're like me then
you're wondering where is Kris Jenner
and the rest of the family like how
you'll want to handle this we're gonna
all go up on him at the Cavs game in
Cleveland tonight or what
Chris just say the word well listen the
Kardashian family have remained silent
but et source says all of this has been
in crisis management mode and they are
all rallying around Chloe adding that
they just want Chloe to focus on what
really matters right now which of course
is her daughter et has learned mom Kris
isn't Cleveland to be by Chloe's side as
she is due to give birth soon and
Keeping Up with the Kardashians he's
currently in production and Purdue
our figuring out how this will play out
next season but is anybody else getting
a horrible case of deja vu
you know Chloe's ex-husband former
Lakers star Lamar Odom put her through
hell and now he's weighing in on this
latest cheating scandal a source tells
et Lamar has been telling close friends
that he genuinely feels bad for Khloe
and I say man Khloe I should put through
enough guys I'll tell you what
somewhere Scott Disick is looking like a
dream man we were rooting for you
Tristan but now we're gonna break down
the 13 ways Khloe can seek revenge on
him I'm sorry I'm actually being told
we're out of time but you know we we
know there's one way Khloe can get back
at him and that's with her revenge body
and someone who knows what it takes to
get that hot bod is ET on lines very own
Fitness Queen feed your bait hi thank
you welcome to the daily Denny thank you
so much for having me oh my god guys
Deidre is here for a shameless plug I
think all of us can benefit from he has
literally tried nearly every workout
there is in Los Angeles can't you tell
it's Fitness is her passion and she
tracks what the celebs are doing a get
fit and stay fit and trust I know from
experience yes you sure do this brave
soul join me for a Raisa nation class
last weekend there is a reason the class
is only 30 minutes you will literally
leave wishing that it was shorter guys
here's the proof what is this after that
all right I just finished my first rise
nation class width of fit spoke Wiener
South Deidre and LeAnn - oh my god I
rather be in bed Udrih hubby do ya you
guys were excellent the form the booties
were popping in the best way how do you
do this every weekend it's okay I really
was dying you guys know you did great
baby stars I like this plan well now
Deidre is bringing one of the hottest
new workouts to you on et's youtube
channel look at away girl that is right
you guys know I don't know who's your
fits both Joe Jonas oh he's a good
choice for me personally it's Selena
Gomez so I went straight to her trainer
Shannon nage who owns hot Pilates in
West
and I got that royal SG treatment now
keep in mind these workouts are done in
a 95 degree heated room so your girl was
Schmitz a little baby here is a taste of
just one of the moves to get Selena's
hot Pilates body bring your legs wide as
wide as you can point your toes out
connect to that core already your brain
is in your stomach bend your knees bring
your tailbone straight down use your
stomach nice
now squeeze your inner thighs to come up
stand nice and tall and bring it down
and squeeze it up and one hold it down a
lot of girls tend to poke the butt out
here save that for the club a little
booty pop a little booty popping always
good from here use your stomach can you
pulse down for five and four good three
nice really feel it right and one hold
it can you lift your right heel up and
then lift your left heel up the feet are
your foundation will cause your feet to
warm up and now pulse to good deidre so
now you're working your inner thighs
your glutes your stomach
abs are tighter and your calves are
burning and you're shaking and I love it
I am shaking just Selena shake I want
this talena shake guys listen no I want
the Selena shake so I did a quick change
thanks for you go for the mic hold on
we're not we're not ready yet
one second all right here we go you guys
you know I was gonna let her leave with
our showing me at least one of those
moves put you to the test let's prove it
I got your mercy okay let's do this
so like Shannon just demonstrated this
is called the plie squat stand straight
legs pointed out arms in a beautiful
second Emmy yes your ballerina arms
thank you now keep your spine straight
like you're up against a wall okay and
you're gonna start to pulse up an inch
down an inch up an inch down an inch
make sure that your butt is still
engaged cuz you know Coachella this
weekend I gotta get your booty pop she's
not wrong okay okay so you're doing
great but I don't see you doing the
Selena shake so let's work a little
harder yes and stay okay okay stay down
stay down now pop your heels whoo and
sit down do little pulses one
- oh what a three four and five
okay the shaking oh yeah it does come
really fast this workout is no joke I
can't believe you did that in heat I'd
also interviewed her I sort of wanted to
die I sort of want to die right now but
you know what it's worth it if you want
the S G bod by summer work that's true I
wanted by this weekend but you know you
actually that was just a taste of it it
was we actually did three of Celina's
go-to moves that Shannon does with her
to get that rocking bod in time for
summer you're gonna want to check it out
yeah you will actually now you can learn
how to get fit just like Selena will
link the full episode in the description
if you're watching this on YouTube
otherwise just head over to e t--'s
youtube channel through the video girl
think wow I mean I'm kind of sweaty I'm
not gonna lie alright guys thanks for
watching watch her show watch my like
comment share we appreciate all the love
we love hear me out I won't walk he
needs a massage
[Music]